depuis 40 ans la foire agricole de
bras-panon est une vitrine de
l'agriculture réunionnaise l'occasion de
réfléchir à des thématiques d'avenir
tels que la sécurité alimentaire
une thématique dont on parle beaucoup
depuis de nombreuses années
cela se définit par une alimentation
accessible disponible de qualité et de
façon stabiliser un défi pour notre
région
nous sommes à une tournée de notre
projet de société qu'on nomme
aujourd'hui un projet de société india
océanique est derrière ce projet il ya
avant tout la sécurité alimentaire ça
veut dire donner à manger à nos
populations pour les années à venir et
aborder le sujet de la pauvreté de ceux
qui ne mangent pas et aussi abordé le
sujet de
comment mieux partager nos richesses
comment mieux produire comment mieux
formés et comment justement ne plus
avoir cette dépendance par rapport au
nord de la planète
la stratégie semble simple chaque pays
de la zone développe ses atouts les
sécuriser ensemble ils recherchent les
voies de développement gagnant gagnant
pas facile comme démarche quand chacun a
ses propres problématiques 80% de notre
dépendance de denrées alimentaires de
l'étranger
alors le fait ce que nous arrivons sur
nous pouvons arriver ici à voir comment
on va produire dans l'ensemble des
territoires de l'océan indien des sondés
pays de la commission de l'océan indien
comment s'approvisionner l'un des deux
est aujourd'hui
nous avons une très grande utilisation
de produits phytosanitaires et l'idée
c'est de diminuer l'utilisation de
produits phytosanitaires pour avoir
produit plus sain et donc qui sera lui
aussi valorisables au niveau local mais
aussi au niveau exploitation dépendant
des différents produits avant de devenir
griene voici indien il faut avoir une
vie toute la population locale de là il
ya quand même un certain nombre de
contraintes il faudra dresser et je
pense que au niveau de ceux qui aiment
la coopération au niveau des expériences
par ailleurs la réunion mais aussi les
autres s'ils servent de pistes pour
resituer l'individu au centre des
préoccupations et peut-être une piste
stratégique anticiper les crises
alimentaires tels que celle de la
filière animale permettra d'assurer un
avenir au pays de la zone
une coopération est essentielle pour le
conseil départemental situé au centre de
cette manifestation
je crois qu'il faut revenir sur une base
vous avez les plantes on élève on pêche
d'abord pour se nourrir et le sait
aujourd'hui c'est comme une démarche et
mondialisation des marchés du profit qui
avait effectivement on tente a exporté
pour de l'argent et on nous proposerait
la population donc je crois qu'il est
extrêmement important dans le règlement
sept soeurs nos besoins remédier à nos
plantes se mange à nombre dans les
apennins plantes
ce n'est pas simple enfin dans
l'angélisme mais je me dis que brandon
l'oignon de magasins patron guerre
contre la carotte reno nev le pool et
rayonne patron guerre contre le le
le port maurice insistante exercée sur
le bon exemple mais nous devons ensemble
doit faire de l' expertise faire des
échanges qu'on ait trouvé les bonnes
solutions économiques pour que nous
soyons à même de concerter à pouvoir
monter dans une ambulance sauvage mais
bien la même dalle alors comment on peut
avancer ensemble pour se nourrir se
marier consommateurs industriels
politiques
l'orientation donnée à la sécurité
alimentaire peut être un élément
déterminant dans les relations india
océanique